étranger
[Musique]
Je vais en Ukraine donc euh grand magasin et
euh je me sens un peu un peu désolé pour
eux d'être juste et j'étais un peu
assez contrarié mais euh tu sais qu'on a
les gens ont besoin de moi ici, je suis un peu
nerveux, je peux être honnête, mais en même
temps, ce n'est pas à propos de moi, il y a les
gens qui souffrent là-bas, donc je
veux dire quand vous voyez les images, vous voyez les
gens qui sont ici juste  maintenant vous
comprenez que vous ne souffrez
plus d'eux
merci
euh et fondamentalement nous sommes ici à cause
des crimes de guerre qui sont commis
évidemment le président a demandé s'il pouvait
aider et j'ai commencé à y penser et
puis j'ai commencé  lire les crimes de guerre
et c'est là que ça devient écoeurant
[Musique]
étrangère